SUBJECT 1: If I told you the
path that these people are
walking on is referred to
as "the most dangerous trail
in the world," I don't think
you'd be too surprised.
They all hugging
a side a mountain,
about 5,000 feet in the air,
hiking on a two-way path.
And believe it or not,
some are doing this just
to go and get a cup of tea.
VIVIAN LEE: Hi, my
name is Vivian Lee.
I'm a keen scuba diver
and amateur photographer,
who works in the
finance industry.
This photo was
taken at Hua Shan,
in the Shaanxi province in
China, in the autumn of 2012.
SUBJECT 1: That's Mount Hua
Shan, one of China's five
sacred mountains.
It's home to ancient
legends and structures,
and of course many
traditions, both new and old.
It is a place where people
once came to worship and seek
immortality, and where
others were taken
to be sacrificed to the gods.
But today, it is a place
for tourists and locals
to enjoy a reflective hike,
with some even leaving a prayer
in the form of a gold lock.
It is a place to express
both your spiritual
and adventurous side,
albeit a dangerous one.
VIVIAN LEE: The most unique
part of this mountain hike
was the cliff side plank walk.
For [INAUDIBLE], we were given
a chest harness, two carabiners,
and with minimal
instructions, off we went.
The most daunting part
of the initial descent
was down a narrow
ladder of iron rods.
With two-way traffic,
there were times
when two people could be
standing on the same rod,
at the same time.
At the bottom of this
makeshift ladder is a two foot
wide plank, to traverse across.
And a metal chain,
on the wall for you
to clip your carabiners
in an alcove,
as you make your way across.
SUBJECT 1: An
estimated 100 people
die every year on
Mount Hua Shan.
But for some, the
risk is worth it.
And their award, one of the
best cups of tea in China.
But for others,
it's a satisfaction
of conquering the most
dangerous path in the world.
VIVIAN LEE: I wanted
to capture the emotions
of these daring hikers.
And at the same time, find
out for myself, what compels
them to take such risks.
What was at the end
of this plank walk?
When we reached the
end, all we found
was a small Taoist shrine.
But I thought it was the
sheer adrenaline of being
in the clouds , that attract
people like myself here.
The tea houses dotted
around the mountain
used to be Taoist temples,
which has now been converted
to allow hikers to
take tea breaks or camp
overnight during their visit.
We also enjoyed a pot of freshly
brewed Chinese tea when we
finally reached the south peak.
This is not for the faint
hearted, or those with vertigo,
but it's definitely
worth a challenge.
SUBJECT 1: Want to see even more
amazing destinations in China,
watch this episode
next to find out where
you can see views like this.
SUBJECT 2: This image
is about the rice fields
in Tuangtang, the
biggest one in China.
I was very lucky, because the
mood of the sky was perfect.
SUBJECT 1: And as always,
don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.